le gia algérien a précisé ces menaces
envers la france et cela au moyen de
messages transmis par l'intermédiaire
d'internet ce réseau informatique qui
relie tous les serveurs de la planète
enquête olivier werner on connaissait
el-ansar considéré par les spécialistes
comme un organe d'expression du gia
bulletin confidentiel véhicule du
message islamique photocopier fax est
distribué sous le manteau
mais il y a aujourd'hui beaucoup plus
sophistiqué tapé qui cela jihad guerre
sainte
ou un autre mot clé voisins et vous
voilà en communication avec les
porte-paroles du gia
grâce au réseau internet l'autoroute de
l'information islam report jihad news
deux fils d'informations crédibles
souvent signées gilles yau à igé groupe
islamique armé ou groupes islamiques
america une signature renforcée par abou
abdellah nadine le nom de guerre de
zitouni chef du gia qui a pris
l'habitude de s'adresser directement à
jacques chirac des informations des
communiqués mais aussi des
avertissements circulent sur ce réseau
libre sans contrôle aucun exemple tôt ce
matin on pouvait lire sur islam report
la résistance islamique algérienne
déclare que la guerre en france va
continuer ce sera les paies ou
l'humiliation c'est écrire majuscule
signe de colère sur internet et plus
loin toujours dans cette même lettre
transmise aujourd'hui nous allons
continuer à frapper au coeur même de la
france et dans les grandes villes pour
contrer le gia sur internet le
gouvernement algérien comme unique lui
aussi en français comme ici les
déclarations d'hervé de charette figure
en bonne place d'aires de communiquer
sur internet où les islamistes montre à
loisir leur détermination argumenté par
de nombreuses citations coranique
internet leur permet de sortir du maquis
et porter leur parole dans le monde
informatique à l'échelle mondiale c'est
bien pourquoi on trouve des centaines de
messages par jour concocté par des
islamistes informaticiens ingénieurs
chercheurs idéologues abritée par les
plus grandes universités qui offre sans
trop le savoir ou le vouloir un
formidable réseau de communication
faux